[Musique]
bonjour emilie bonnivard merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
mt france il ya donc ce nouveau conseil
de défense ce matin on va savoir si les
remontées mécaniques restent fermées ou
pas ça a pas l'air d'être le cas en tout
cas c'est mal parti pour la réouverture
pour les vacances de février vous êtes
député de savoie vous avez déjà
interpeller le gouvernement et envoyé
une lettre à emmanuel macron sur cette
question quel est votre état d'esprit ce
matin bien évidemment c'est l'inquiétude
qui qui prime ce matin car l'économie de
la montagne fait vivre des régions
entières non seulement évidemment tous
les commerces et les zac l'activité
économique propre aux stations mais en
savoie haute savoie en isère cette
économie elle irrigue véritablement
toute l'économie de nos vallées et les
font vivre à l'année donc une ouverture
pour nous c'est évidemment
catastrophique pour nos stations pour
leur avenir pour l'investissement dont
elles ont besoin à l'avenir puisque cet
investissement sera forcément ralenti et
c'est également une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour toute l'économie de nos
territoires en savoir le ski la montagne
c'est 50 % de notre pib
c'est 50% de la création notre richesse
c'est beaucoup d'entreprises qui
dépendent dans les vallées de cette
activité est pour vous les aides de
l'état ne peuvent pas suffire à a porté
à bout de bras en tout cas cette
économie en attendant des jours
meilleurs
les aides de les trains ne vont pas
compensé les pertes de chiffre
d'affaires de l'économie réelle
donc nous ce que nous voulions c'est
ouvrir dans des conditions sanitaires
contrainte
quitte à limiter le périmètre de
personnes pouvant accéder aux volontés
mécanique faire des ouvertures au niveau
régional pour éviter les les grands
déplacements de population mais c'était
ouvrir véritablement
l'eau station avec des protocoles center
exigeant on ne comprend toujours pas
pourquoi on peut prendre le métro à
aller travailler en métro et ne pas
prendre les remontées mécaniques
cette économie de tourisme nous c'est
une économie qui nous fait manger c'est
notre gagne pain
donc c'est exactement comme les
personnes qui vont dans le métro on a
toujours du mal à comprendre et on pense
qu'avec les ouvertures à périmètre
réduit
on aurait quand même pu travailler un
peu quand même dégagé un peu d'activité
et de création de valeur pour pouvoir
irriguer notre économie un peu mieux
toute l'année les aides elles n'aident
pas à compenser la perte de chiffre
d'affaires on n'est pas dans une
économie dirigée
heureusement et vivement que ça s'arrête
car ceux qui créent de l'emploi de la
richesse c'est le travail
ce ne sont pas les aides de l'état qui
sont des impôts en devenir
voilà les impôts en devenir généralement
elle plombe il plombe encore un peu plus
notre est connu sur la campagne de
vaccination le premier ministre jean
castex a été hué hier à l'assemblée
nationale par votre famille politique
regardé et on en parle après comme nous
l'avions prévu et nous l'avons même
anticiper la montée en charge la
vaccination va s'accélérer nous avons
pour objectif dans les ehpad droit ça se
travaille de consentement que nous avons
recueilli des vaccinés à hauteur de 430
mille personnes que vous auriez vous dit
si nous nous ayons si nous nous étions
précipitée et que le nombre de et que le
taux de personnes vaccinées
c'est un peu mitigé on les entend mal
ils disent rond les vaccins c'est ce
qu'ont dit les députés
il y a un peu plus de cinq cent mille
personnes qui sont vaccinées à ce jour
où sont passés les autres doses
en principe il y en a encore cinq cent
mille ha disponibles alors que la
quasi-totalité des plateformes des
rendez-vous sont saturés quel est votre
sentiment sur cette stratégie
gouvernementale
c'est une c'est une grande déception
parce que c'est la première fois dans
cette crise que le gouvernement avait
vraiment les moyens d'anticiper
on se prépare en compte la crise nous
est tombé dessus en mars
le virus nous est tombé dessus veut dire
qu'effectivement c'était compliqué on
n'avait pas de masque alors au départ
nous l'indiquons areva a besoin c'était
un peu gros mais en tout cas on comprend
les contraintes liées à une crise à une
adaptation d'un pays des moyens de
production des chaînes logistiques
immédiatement à une clé sauf que là on
avait peut-être plus plus de deux -
trois mois pour organiser une logistique
de vestes de vaccination qui soit
efficace
encore une fois le gouvernement a
attendu le dernier moment et n'a pas
saisi la main tendue par les
collectivités locales qui lui ont
proposé d'organiser des centres de
vaccination au plus près des territoires
il ya des régions comme la région
auvergne rhône-alpes qui a organisé des
tests massif au mois de décembre avec
l'ensemble des maires avec énormément de
collectivités locales on a pu faire des
centres de vaccination au plus près du
territoire en terme de logistique les
choses se sont bien passées
on aurait pu anticiper de deux mois
cette ses besoins logistiques bien
évidemment cette organisation et non pas
organiser les choses
en gros en deux semaines la semaine
précédente on a eu des réunions sur le
terrain nous a quand même demandé à nos
députés d'informer les personnes de plus
de 75 ans dans nos communes d'aller se
faire vacciner
visibilité c'est ce cri reprocher le
manque de transparence
les élus locaux ne savent pas très bien
combien de doses il y a de disponible
combien de doses vont arriver c'est ça
qui pêche selon vous dans cette
stratégie là on est vraiment sur une
gestion à la petite semaine
moi j'ai tous les jours des personnes
qui m'appelle des des parents des
enfants pardon de personnes âgées qui
m'appelle qui m'indique mais on comprend
pas on n'arrive pas à joindre le numéro
pour la vaccination
les centres sont trop loin je n'habite
pas à côté de ma mère mon père je ne
sais pas comment je vais la véhiculer
pour aller se faire vacciner
et pareil pour les hôpitaux privés qui
ont pu au départ prendre des rendez vous
depuis les rendez-vous ont été annulés
c'est une cacophonie qui est qu'il n'est
pas à la hauteur d'un pays comme la
france pour la gestion d'une vaccination
de grande ampleur sachant que nous
aurions pu anticiper où il ya des choses
que nous avons fait mieux que nos
voisins il s'agit bien protéger les
populations là la vaccination on est
mauvais il faut vraiment en tirer les
conséquences pour rectifier le tir le
plus rapidement possible merci bien sûr
à redon malheureusement nous n'avons
plus le temps
merci en tout cas d'avoir répondu en
direct ce matin à nos questions sur arte
france